dans quelques jours dimanche le Sénat
aura peut-être basculé à droite
publicitaire bien sûr vous propose
depuis quelques semaines une série
d'émissions spéciales dont bien sûr
public sur public c'est la preuve par 3
avant Pierre Laurent le secrétaire
national du PCF et sénateur jeudi nous
recevons aujourd'hui le président du
groupe centriste l'influent groupe
centriste Françoise okto bonsoir bonsoir
et merci d'être avec nous au groupe
influent car charnière et puis vous avez
noué pour ce scrutin de dimanche des
alliances avec l'UMP pour une nouvelle
majorité de centres droits avec moi
cette semaine Déborah Claude de l'ASP
notre partenaire comme chaque semaine
avec Dailymotion et bien sûr Perrine
Tarnaud de Public Sénat d'abord au delà
des clivages politiques l'unité
nationale dans la guerre prévôt la
guerre comme le dit Barack Obama contre
les djihadistes de l'organisation état
islamique le mot et le bon il ne fait
pas de doute c'est une guerre oui bien
sûr c'est une guerre qui est nécessaire
car il n'y a pas d'autres solutions que
de tenter de d'éradiquer cette menace
islamiste qui qui s'exprime de façon
barbare en Irak en Syrie mais qui peut
aussi trouver à s'exprimer dans beaucoup
d'endroits du monde y compris sur notre
continent et est-ce que si on s'en tient
ce qui se passe notamment en Irak et en
Syrie l'ennemi c'est-à-dire c'était
cette islamisme radical peut être vaincu
uniquement avec des bombes bien sûr que
non je suis pas un spécialiste de la
défense mais on sait très bien que tout
ce qui tourne aussi autour du
renseignement est très important et là
la France a un rôle déterminant à jouer
et puis il faut qu'il y ait une
conscience nationale une conscience même
internationale pour lutter pour chaque
citoyen se sente motivés donc il y a pas
que les bombes qui sont nécessaires mais
elles ne sont pas suffisait cette
conscience
doit également être celle des pays
arabes et d'ailleurs on peut constater
que le président américain a fortement
souligné qu'il avait bombardé pour la
première fois la Syrie avec de plusieurs
pays arabes bien sûr c'est important il
s'agit pas d'opposer le monde arabe au
monde
occidental à l'Europe aux Etats-Unis le
problème est mondial et donc il faut
dépasser ce clivage et un certain nombre
de pays arabes j'espère de très nombreux
ou un rôle à jouer avec nous la France
est confrontée par ailleurs dans ce
contexte à une nouvelle prise de tâches
en Algérie le guide de haute montagne
Hervé Gourdel la France et François
Hollande ont raison de dire qu'il n'est
pas question de céder à l'ultimatum des
ravisseurs bien sûr nous sommes
totalement solidaires de cette position
quelle que soit la barbarie commise et
justement parce que ce sont des actes
barbares la menace qui pèse
nous avons affaire à des gens qui sont
déséquilibrés on dirait dans le langage
commun
galvauder un peu ce sont ce sont des
fous il y a des une paranoïaque et
développée par ces gens-là ils sont
accessibles à aucun mode de raisonnement
donc il y a pas d'autres solutions
malheureusement que de les éradiquer
parce que pour vous François Hollande en
chef de guerre ou dans sa politique
internationale lui qui est si contesté
si décrié si Raï et si impopulaire
est-ce qu'il vous paraît là
irréprochable nous nous le suivons et je
pense que tous les Français tous les
groupes politiques suivent la démarche
du gouvernement c'est une démarche
partagée sur ce sujet François Hollande
c'est écouté le la vie des uns et des
autres et il y a un consensus qui s'est
dessiné vous-même vous serez à Matignon
demain vous espérez des précisions
qu'avez-vous envie de demander par
exemple l'exécutif au Premier ministre
c'est ce genre de réunion n'est pas que
formelle car j'ai le souvenir d'avoir
été convoqué à une réunion du même type
concernant un éventuel engagement de la
France en Syrie il y a quelques temps et
nous étions un certain nombre dont
moi-même à ne pas vouloir que la France
s'engage en Syrie c'était d'autres
circonstances et je regrette pas que le
gouvernement nous a écouté à l'époque il
n'était pas encore temps à l'époque
c'est ce que prétend aujourd'hui
François Hollande justement intervenir
en Syrie comme il l'avait proposé avant
de suivre des États-Unis ça aurait été
une grave erreur pour la France que
d'intervenir en Syrie à l'époque
aujourd'hui les circonstances sont
différentes il nous faut intervenir en
Irak et sur une partie de la Syrie
contre le cet état qui se définit en
tout cas comme un état djihadiste
aujourd'hui nous le voyons bien en Syrie
nous avons le même ennemi commun que
Bachar el-Assad donc les djihadistes de
cette organisation état islamique est-ce
que ça nous oblige à regarder
différemment le dictateur évidemment il
y a des principes de réalité qui qui
s'imposent
là nous avons affaire à un adversaire
qui est commun qui au-delà de la de la
destruction de la de la zone cherche à
détruire le monde entier c'est un
phénomène qui est totalement irrationnel
en tout cas il se trouve que nous avons
une cause commune ça veut pas dire que
nous soutenons le régime de Bachard la
France n'a pas peur à lancer le ministre
de l'Intérieur Bernard Cazeneuve et on
peut quand même ça la remet légitimement
notamment de l'appel à tuer
les mécréants que nous sommes selon les
djihadistes évidemment il faut être
lucide il faut pas être naïf il faut se
donner les moyens de protéger nos pays
néanmoins nous ne pouvons pas être
suspects de la moindre faiblesse donc il
faut être courageux c'est vrai comment
est-ce que vous réagissez quand vous
découvrez que près de 1000 français se
sont enrôlés dans dans le jihad
notamment en partant pour la Syrie mais
je pense que c'est l'expression
chez des jeunes d'une grande
désespérance peut-être aussi chez
certains de troubles qui trouvent ainsi
à s'exprimer
ce sont obligatoirement des personnes en
situation de faiblesse qui sont ainsi
récupérés par des thèmes
irrationnels et il peut y avoir chez des
jeunes à un moment simplement victime
dans brigadement sur internet ça
correspond pas ça peut pas correspondre
à une démarche
réfléchie on a connu dans une moindre
mesure ce type de dérive chez les
Brigades Rouges chez Action Directe
évidemment c'était des phénomènes
confinés aujourd'hui la religion à Bondo
et il s'agit d'un entre lavage de
cerveau en brigadement
les on comprend bien que les djihadistes
utilisent la faiblesse voir l'âge
cette inquiétant de découvrir autant de
faiblesses dans les cerveaux et c'est
très inquiétant mais c'est la réalité
humaine et nous devons en tenir compte
et Marine Le Pen a raison de dire ce qui
partent je m'en fiche tout ce qui
m'intéresse c'est surtout qu'il ne
revienne pas on sait pas aussi simple
dans chaque famille il peut y avoir des
esprits perdus je lui dis tout à l'heure
il y a aussi des gens qui sont peut-être
passagèrement pas en mesure de tenir
tout leur équilibre bon il faut essayer
en tout cas de contrôler le phénomène et
je pense avec la plus grande rigueur et
il faut pas prendre ça les légères en
tous les cas sur ces questions là bien
sûr l'unité nationale s'impose
quel jugement portez-vous on a parlé de
François Hollande et globalement sur sur
le couple exécutif et sur Manuel Valls
alors le problème de la tête appréciée
au-delà des personnes de François
Hollande et de Manuel Valls moi je me
demande si les difficultés que nous
constatons dans le fonctionnement de nos
institutions depuis quelques mois et on
peut dire même depuis l'élection de
François Hollande sont pallier à une fin
de régime disons-le probablement que nos
institutions ne sont plus adaptées vous
allez beaucoup plus loin que ceux qui
évoquent une éventuelle crise de régime
vous dites c'est la fin d'un régime on
peut se poser la question quand on voit
que les choses ne fonctionnent plus
quand on voit la faiblesse de l'exécutif
qui pourtant est représentée par un
couple alors est-ce que c'est cette
dualité de l'exécutif qui marque la
faiblesse de l'exécutif peut-être
on devrait s'interroger pour savoir si
un exécutif menait ses fan ne serait pas
plus productif et dès lors qu'il serait
le représentant du peuple direct
c'est-à-dire un régime classique
parlementaire d'une certaine manière
François Hollande je disais que
populaire parce qu'il est un peu victime
des désinstitutions et de révolutions il
est responsable de la situation qu'il a
voulu et qu'il entretient mais je me dis
que nous devrions saisir cette occasion
peut-être pour aller au-delà dans la
réflexion et nous dire est-ce qu'il y a
pas des choses qui ne vont plus dans nos
institutions alors je sais bien que
c'est pas une question qui préoccupe les
Français au quotidien néanmoins ça a de
telles répercussions dans la vie
quotidienne par exemple sur l'emploi sur
l'organisation territoriale sur les
services à la population qu'on doit se
poser la question aujourd'hui vous
voudriez que le chef de l'État se
contente d'être un arbitre et que la
politique soit effectivement la
politique de la nation soit
effectivement dirigée par le
gouvernement donc par le Premier
ministre c'est tonton d'emprunter cette
voie ce sera aussi un retour au
fondement de la Cinquième République ce
serait aussi
nous nous aligner sur les régimes
voisins qui en Europe et dans les
grandes démocraties fonctionnent de
cette façon est-ce que vous réclamez
vous aussi une sixième république du
coup j'irai pas jusqu'à parler de
Sixième République mais jusqu'à soit un
retour à la version originale de la
Cinquième République soit
quelqu'un oui mais justement c'est le
quinquennat qui a tout bouleversé quel
est le rôle d'un parlement quand vous
avez la Chambre des députés l'Assemblée
nationale qui est élu dans la foulée du
président de la République
quelle est-il en tout cas il est très en
moins de riz est-ce que Manuel Valls a
raison de demander à Angela Merkel et au
peuple allemand a-t-il dit de faire
confiance à la France
la démarche de Manuel Valls et difficile
d'abord elle est difficile à percevoir
par les Allemands tant le décalage dans
le raisonnement politique et économique
est important entre nos amis allemands
et nous-mêmes les Allemands ne nous
comprennent plus ils comprennent pas le
double discours en tout cas le décalage
entre le discours et la réalité en
France alors dans ce contexte pour le
Premier ministre français c'est très
difficile d'abord comme nous venons de
le voir il représente une partie de
l'exécutif au-dessus de lui il y a le
président de la République qui peut
toujours dire quelque chose de différent
donc c'est très difficile pour lui et
puis les Allemands ont un langage qui
est peut-être trop constant que nous
voudrions plus souple mais qui a le
mérite d'être clair c'est à dire vous
réduisez les déficits vous redonner de
la productivité des gains à l'industrie
vous exportez et vous verrez la
croissance et l'emploi revenir mais
est-ce que Paris a raison de dire qu'il
faut quand même relancer par exemple les
investissements réellement notamment
pour relancer la croissance européenne
oui je pense que les Allemands peuvent
écouter et dès lors qu'ils ont des
capacités de relancer l'investissement
mais de façon raisonnable de façon
progressive ils doivent nous aider je
pense que l'Allemagne même si elle est
le pays le plus puissant actuellement de
l'Union européenne l'Allemagne a besoin
des autres pays européens et notamment
de la France on sait bien que la France
est d'une zone d'exportation
déterminante pour l'économie allemande
vous avez dit que le Président de la
République est le premier ministre
peuvent parfois ne pas toujours tenir le
même discours vous n'avez pas noté quand
même de désaccord là entre François
Hollande Emmanuel Valls sur le cap
économique et sur les grandes questions
internationales non mais il faut
observer qu'il est parfois difficile de
de comprendre ce que veut le président
de la République donc Manuel Valls c'est
assez clair pour le président Hollande
c'est plus compliqué à décrypter alors
Alain Juppé considère qu'on a un peu
perdu le centre
pourtant là vous êtes là en face de nous
ce soir alors où est-il où est-ce que
vous vous situez dans l'appel au grand
rassemblement certains voient plutôt une
OPA lancée par Nicolas Sarkozy c'est ce
que vous allez nous dire donc dans un
instant en répondant à Deborah Claude de
l'Agence France Presse avant donc
de voir comment le retour de Nicolas
Sarkozy bouscule aussi le centre Jérôme
Rabier
il est de retour veut faire exploser les
vieux clivages rassembler en dépassant
le cadre des parties lui c'est
évidemment Nicolas Sarkozy et quand il
parle rassemblement forcément les
regards se tournent vers le centre mais
l'ex-président candidat à la tête de
l'UMP l'a promis il a changé et ses
proches la firme pas question de
froisser ses anciens alliés on voulait
rassurer nos émissions tristes pour leur
dire que la hauteur de Nicolas Sarkozy
c'était pas le retour du RPR il va pas
faire une OPA agressive sur l'idée il
est certainement pas on s'entend bien
partout on fait des listes communes au
sénatorial on va faire des listes
communes ou régionales au cantonales on
va être ensemble on peut aussi peut-être
trouver un système qui fasse qu'on
puisse se fédérer un peu plus c'est tout
une approche en douceur qui pourrait
favoriser les ralliements individuels
mais pour Chantal Jouanneau ex-ministre
de Nicolas Sarkozy ayant ensuite rejoint
le Daily pas question de changer la
stratégie du parti ça la change pas du
tout au contraire j'allais dire que ça
la renforce
parce que le retour de Nicolas Sarkozy
ça va clarifier les positions de la
droite on connaît son discours mais on
sait surtout la réalité la réalité c'est
que il porte un projet d'une droite
conservatrice s'il prend l'UMP Nicolas
Sarkozy qu'on ne faire table rase du
passé et reconstruire un nouveau
rassemblement en moins de 3 mois un peu
rapide pour convaincre les cadres du
modèle en trois mois en temps de Nicolas
Sarkozy un nouveau grand parti et qui
aurait une nouvelle proposition une
nouvelle organisation nous nous pensons
que c'est quelque chose qui est plutôt
aujourd'hui de nature à stériliser le
débat alors est-ce que certains
centrices rejoindront Nicolas Sarkozy
très vite ou pas je n'en sais rien en
tout cas je vous assure qu'il viendront
pas du MoDem cela au MoDem François
Bayrou n'a jamais caché qu'il était bien
plus proche d'Alain Juppé et si c'est
vieux complices s'opposent à l'arrivée
de Nicolas Sarkozy la stratégie à long
terme ne semble pas bien différente je
pense que la droite et le centre doivent
se rassembler pour redonner un espoir à
la France donc nous allons chacun à
notre manière et avec notre style et
contribué rassembler la droite et les
centriste c'était la raison d'être de
l'UMP à sa création 12 ans plus tard la
donne n'a pas changé les centristes sont
toujours autant courtisés
voilà Déborah Claude est avec nous
bonsoir cher Déborah vos questions donc
à Françoise okto sur majestement tous
ces sourires à destination du centre des
souris ou des je ne fais pas des crocs
de Nicolas Sarkozy et ce qu'on va se
programme de créer un rassemblement très
très large qui pourrait inclure le
centre il faut analyser les choses dans
l'ordre aujourd'hui Nicolas Sarkozy
revient parce qu'il est candidat à la
présidence de l'UMP alors nous en tant
que centriste nous sentons pas du tout
concernés c'est un problème interne à
l'UMP et le débat se situe à l'intérieur
de l'UMP vous voulez de cette affaire
absolument pas absolument pas puisque
l'UDI qui est un parti maintenant bien
constitué bien représenté sur tous les
territoires de France a lui aussi son
propre processus de désignation du
président
on en parle beaucoup moins peut-être
mais vous savez chaque fédération les
candidats il y a quatre candidats qui a
un vrai débat aussi qui se situe au sein
de l'univers on veut être indépendant
par rapport à l'UMP en campagne on
imagine d'ailleurs assez mal qui disent
le contraire mais bien sûr mais ça
correspond aussi à un ressenti profond
chez tous les militants et tous les élus
de l'udié nous n'avons pas créé l'UDI
pour nous dissoudre dans une autre
formation dont on imagine mal les
contours
du MP mais il a aussi le projet de faire
quelque chose qui dépasse les clivages
attendons de voir déjà l'issue du
démarre à l'UMP et ensuite nous verrons
non mais on dit pas non à travailler
ensemble d'ailleurs vous le voyez vous
pour les élections sénatoriales pour les
prochaines départementales les
prochaines régionales nous sommes
probablement invités à travailler
ensemble maintenant partenariat ne veut
pas dire fusion assimilation donc vous
êtes d'accord avec François Bayrou qui a
répété ce week-end à ces universités de
rentrée ou d'ailleurs Jean Arthur était
je crois vendredi soir pas de partie
unique à droite c'est la droite là sont
le centre c'est le centre ça cette
philosophie là elle vous correspond
sans aucune hésitation
donc on ne refait pas l'UMP
mais c'est pas un peu ce qui cherche à
refaire
je vous dis Nicolas Sarkozy aujourd'hui
s'intéresse à l'UMP bon pas seulement
en énergie et sa capacité à aller très
vite la notion droit comme un vieux
tapis pour les centres c'est pas le
sujet c'est pas le sujet que l'élection
de l'UMP nous nous avons notre propre
élection et nous avons nos propres
sujets de discussion tout petit peu un
sujet parce que là on a eu un communiqué
cet après-midi de Valérie leter une
ancienne ministre de Sarkozy qui est
obligée de faire un communiqué pour non
je n'irai pas au meeting de Lambersart
jeudi est-ce que des rumeurs circulaient
donc on voit bien quand même il y a des
forces d'attraction assez importante
des rumeurs parfois les rumeurs peuvent
confiner à la manipulation Valérie
Létard est un parlementaire influente
dans la région Nord-Pas-de-Calais qui
peut aussi avoir des défis importants à
relever l'année prochaine et
probablement que l'UMP souhaite
entretenir des liens proches avec elle
mais la raison de résister
même pas poser la question
c'est une réunion interne à l'UMP elle
n'a pas de raison de se rendre à cette
réunion Nicolas Sarkozy tenait meeting à
Laval votre ville est-ce que vous iriez
parce que j'ai pas entendu non je
n'aurais pas parce que par respect pour
mes collègues avec lequel je travaille
d'ailleurs élu de l'UMP et militant
UMP je considère si une affaire
importante pour eux qui n'a pas à être
pollué ou transformer
par d'autres par d'autres débats donc
une fois nous au centre nous existons
nous avons nos propres groupes
parlementaires nous sommes engagés dans
des élections c'est vrai souvent avec un
processus d'alliance de partenariat avec
l'UMP et nous avons notre propre
indépendance comment l'avez-vous trouvé
Nicolas Sarkozy dimanche soir l'avez
vous trouvez changer oui j'ai trouvé un
petit peu changé probablement par
l'expérience et le recul qu'il a pris
par rapport à la vie politique il est
certain qu'il a beaucoup consulté il a
certainement écouté il a aussi voyagé
maintenant il échappe
il a certainement consulté des
centristes certainement mais il consulte
beaucoup de
téléphone
de Jean-Luc Borlo et encore moins sur
celui de Nicolas Sarkozy fait figure
d'homme providentiel pour vous
en providentiel c'est quelque chose dont
on se méfie en France
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure à
réticence par rapport aux exécutifs qui
qui
ne Converse qu'entre eux quand ils sont
vissés
dans les propos qu'il a pu tenir
dimanche soir je crois qu'il est
volontaire il est sincère
sur justement sur la forme on change pas
le personnage il est toujours aussi
dynamique il a une capacité aussi à
mobiliser à rassembler c'est exact
maintenant pour le moment
de janvier
pour Nicolas Sarkozy aux alentours de la
prison au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle j'avais soutenu François
Bayrou et au second tour j'avais indiqué
que mon choix entre les deux candidats
se portait pour Nicolas Sark
se dessinent alors en voyant un peu plus
loin que la présidence de l'UMP François
bayrouk vous avez parfois accompagné lui
est plutôt sur la ligne d'Alain Juppé ça
c'est aussi une autre tonalité qui peut
vous parler qui peut vous conv mais
Alain Juppé c'est aussi quelqu'un de
très respectable et d'expérimenter qui a
aussi certainement une capacité à
prendre des grandes responsabilités mais
il est engagé dans un débat interne à
l'UMP il est engagé pour la primaire de
2016 qui est vous l'avez entendu dans le
reportage juste avant et il parle de
vous descentrices oui nous avons la
sympathie pour un GPS
avec le Centre mettez un peu mieux si si
tout le monde veut travailler avec le
Centre vous vous souvenez qui à la
présidence de l'UDI puisqu'il y a quatre
candidats une élection dont on parle peu
sarkozygo Morin moi je suis président de
groupe vous savez j'ai la difficile
tâche de faire vivre ensemble et surtout
travailler ensemble des personnes qui
ont parfois des sensibilités un petit
peu diverses c'est la spécificité du
groupe centriste c'est ce qui fait aussi
sa force donc je ne me suis pas engagé
derrière l'un ou l'autre des candidats
je les connais bien ils ont chacun leurs
qualité je pense qu'il faut laisser les
militants libres de leur choix ainsi que
les élus du groupe
non parce que franchement je n'ai pas de
je n'ai pas de à faire cette annonce
d'accord François Bayrou a réclamé une
dissolution vous avez fait état de vos
réflexions tout à l'heure sur
non pas la crise de régime enfin les
difficultés selon vous qui découlent du
quinquennat notamment est-ce que vous
estimez que la demande du président du
MoDem est fondée en raison de la
situation politique actuelle dans notre
pays il y a beaucoup de raisons qui
militent pour que
l'exécutif actuel en tout cas dans sa
forme gouvernementale c'est-à-dire le
Premier ministre est féministe nous
poursuivent pas leur mission car nous
sommes en situation d'échec le problème
c'est que une dissolution à mon avis
n'apporterait pas de solution au
problème quotidiens des Français
aujourd'hui pour deux raisons
premièrement parce que celui qui décide
tout dans notre système ou qui a la
capacité de tout empêcher
déstabilisé le fonctionnement de nos
institutions et aujourd'hui on en mesure
les conséquences néfastes est-ce qu'on
n'est pas un peu parfois c'est ce qu'on
se demande en campagne permanente pour
la présidentielle là Alain Juppé dit le
match a commencé pour 2017 vous même
vous nous dites attendez on est il y a
une campagne interne à l'UMP ils sont un
petit peu
comment dire il se mélange un peu les
pinceaux avec les deux échéances
toutes les vies politiques françaises
depuis quelques années et centré sur
l'élection présidentielle c'est-à-dire
qu'à peine un président était élu que
l'on parle déjà le présidentiel
suivantes moyennant quoi les
responsables politiques ne travaillent
pas suffisamment sur le programme
de parlementaires et oui font des
promesses Inconsidérées enfin il y a
toutes sortes de dérives donc c'est très
mauvais pour notre pays et évidemment
très mauvais pour le quotidien des
Français
sont en situation d'échec vous ne pensez
pas du tout la pousser à la possibilité
d'un retournement d'ici 2017 non j'y
crois pas parce que je pense que les
réformes de structure qui sont à faire
comme par exemple la modification des
sur les 35 heures
des réformes territoriales
enfin compréhensible
certaines réformes aussi du droit du
travail ne sont pas faites
c'est toujours le double langage c'est à
dire que on a Manuel Valls qui dit je
comprends les préoccupations des
entreprises et puis à côté il y a le
président de la République voire même
Manuel Valls lui-même le lendemain qui
qui donne un signal contraire pour tenir
une majorité très fébrile très très
volatile au Parlement donc si on reste
en situation d'échec en corps pendant
plusieurs années ce que vous craignez
que des étincelles mettre le feu à ce
pays c'est la crainte beaucoup de
responsables en effet je pense qu'on n'a
pas pris suffisamment la mesure du fait
que le premier parti de France est
probablement le Front national
aujourd'hui que le Front national dans
sa configuration actuelle est
susceptible de s'approcher de l'entrée
de l'Élysée et je le dis avec beaucoup
de gravité je pense que on ferait bien
de réfléchir à cela et de se dire et de
se dire comment en sommes-nous arrivés
là
comment
par exemple le gouvernement aujourd'hui
François Hollande est-il si éloigné des
préoccupations des Français voilà il y a
un problème il y a une coupure qui est
réelle
région assez agricole on a vu qu'à
Morlaix ce weekend il y a eu des
incidents quand même très grave
je suis maire et pour la première fois
qu'on s'est municipal nous avons la
présence d'un représentant du Front
National et ce Front national a été lu
dans les quartiers qui concentre le plus
grand les plus grandes difficultés de
mes concitoyens c'est à dire difficultés
de logement
chômage
présence de population étrangères que
qui sont difficiles à comprendre par les
par les habitants enfin vous voyez les
Nicolas Sarkozy n'a pas une force
particulière pour séduire et refaire
revenir les électeurs du Front national
dans le Gironde républicain peut-être
mais il n'y a pas que Nicolas Sarkozy
qui doit se préoccuper de cette
situation difficile
vous dites il y a plein de réformes à
faire alors est-ce qu'il faudrait un
candidat centriste à la présidentielle
la vraie question qu'il faudra se poser
mais on se la posera en temps utile
c'est de savoir si
vu l'état de du pays et notamment les
possibilités pour le Front national
d'être au deuxième tour de savoir
comment il faut aborder
le premier tour
pour avoir la certitude que les idées
que nous représentons soient dans le
débat au deuxième tour en d'autres
termes si
absolument ce qui supposerait qu'il y
ait une primaire ouverte au centre que
vous réclamez
c'est sans doute une bonne idée pour
créer une adhésion complète autour du
candidat de la droite et du centre s'il
ne doit y en avoir qu'un seul face aux
candidats du Front national merci
Deborah
arrive maintenant on va donc parler des
sénatoriales dimanche mais vous faites
quel est l'enjeu de ce scrutin et
comment se déroule-t-il on sait qu'il
est ouvert uniquement au seul grand
électeurs Marie bremo
il n'y a que 178 sièges à prendre à la
Haute Assemblée mais ils sont 1733
candidats en rêvé un record un nombre
jusqu'ici jamais atteint dans quelques
jours c'est donc la moitié du Sénat qui
sera renouvelée 59 départements 4
collectivités d'outre-mer et 6 des 12
sièges de la circonscription des
Français établis hors de France un
renouvellement partiel au mode de
scrutin particulier le suffrage
universel indirect dimanche
87534 grands électeurs iront voté pour
élire les sénateurs pour un mandat de 6
ans le collège électoral dans chaque
département est composé en réalité de
grands élus locaux les mers un certain
nombre de conseillers municipaux et dans
les grandes villes de délégués désignés
par les conseils municipaux on ajoute à
cela les conseillers généraux les
conseillers régionaux et les députés les
élections sénatoriales mélangent deux
types de scrutins coûte un majoritaire à
deux tours dans les départements qui lis
seulement un ou deux sénateurs étaient
lu celui qui obtient au premier tour la
majorité absolue des suffrages exprimés
le scrutin majoritaire concernent ici 59
sièges autre mode de scrutin la
représentation proportionnelle dans les
départements où sont au moins élus trois
sénateurs dans un département vous avez
x siège de sénateurs à pourvoir vous
avez un certain nombre de listes et bien
on attribue les sièges des sénateurs en
proportion du nombre de voies obtenues
par chaque liste et là cela concerne 119
sièges même si rien n'est joué il est
fort probable que le Sénat bascule à
droite compte tenu des élections
municipales de mars dernier la vague
bleue pourrait donc s'emparer également
du Sénat finalement la plus forte
incertitude concerne la présidence de la
haute assemblée qui pour accéder au
Plateau
voilà quelle sera alors le choix des
centristes on a envie de le savoir aussi
Françoise okto Perrine Tarnaud nous a
rejoints
vont commencer au Sénat il y a plus
beaucoup de doutes sur le fait que la
Haute Assemblée devrait basculer à
droite dimanche soir quel est votre
pronostic à vous dites il n'y a plus de
doute mais douloureux dans le reportage
nous avons entendu rien n'est joué moi
je considère que rien n'est joué en
effet le corps électoral du Sénat et peu
mobile il est je vais pas dire qu'il est
figé mais il a quand même bougé avec les
dernières élections municipales nous
sommes dans une configuration où il peut
y avoir quelques sièges en effet des
cars dans un sens ou dans l'autre donc
nous restons très prudents vous restez
prudent mais vous ne considérez pas
quand même que la situation politique
actuelle et puis également les grands
enjeux pour cette campagne à savoir la
réforme territoriale la baisse des
dotations public aux collectivités tout
ça ça ne joue pas contre l'actuel
gouvernement et donc contre la majorité
de gauche évidemment les thèmes que vous
évoquez la baisse des dotations sans
précédent de l'État qui rend la gestion
des collectivités locales très
difficiles les transferts de compétences
non compensées telles que l'affaire des
rythmes scolaires
les l'inflation normative qui met aussi
les communes les départements les
communautés de communes dans une
seringue financière dont on sait pas
comment s'en sortir la réforme
territoriale non maîtrisée on vous
demande tout ça ne plaise pas en faveur
en faveur du gouvernement des réformes
il y a un instant au bout de monde aussi
aux collectivités locales de vous
réfléchir bien sûr la réforme
territoriale tout à l'heure mais juste
pour finir sur sur les élections
sénatoriales on a l'impression qu'ici le
Sénat est déjà tourné vers le deuxième
rang de ces élections sénatoriales à
savoir la bataille pour le plateau
c'est-à-dire pour la présidence du
sénatou se joue beaucoup entre Gérard
Jean-Pierre Raffin c'est un peu le
remake de ce qui s'était passé en 2008
est-ce que vous les sentiers que vous
avez aussi envie de vous compter et de
compter dans cette bataille pour la
présidence et donc de présenter un
candidat et nous prendrons notre
décision lorsque le groupe sera réuni au
complexe c'est-à-dire mardi matin
prochain c'est bien les victimes
d'attendre de savoir qui va être élu et
qui va qui va siéger avant de décider
mais nous avons vocation dès lors que la
primaire organisée au sein du MP est une
primaire fermée qui n'intéresse que les
USB nous avons vocation de façon très
légitime à exprimer notre projet pour le
Sénat et être présent au premier tour de
l'élection
légitime selon vous qu'il y ait un
candidat centriste au premier tour de
cette de cette élection est-ce qu'il y a
pas quand même entre Gérard larf Gérard
Larcher Jean-Pierre Raffarin des deux
candidats qui seraient un peu plus sans
trop compatible on va dire franchement
non et le groupe n'a émis aucune opinion
sur le sujet et c'est un débat que nous
n'avons pas au sein de notre un groupe
nous nous souhaitons
qui aussi d'origine
gaulliste social donc c'est un peu
transversalents
de débaucher un peu certaines voix chez
les centrises ou de le sentir ça quand
même non
processus était en deux temps et que
nous ne serons pas conviés à désigner le
candidat de l'UMP ce qui est normal nous
sommes extérieurs à ce débat parce que
ça vous inquiète de voir que finalement
les Français s'intéressent pas du tout à
ce scrutin le dimanche oui bien sûr ça
pose la question de du corps électoral
du Sénat et moi je serai pas choquée
qu'à l'avenir le Sénat et non seulement
un mode de fonctionnement différent mais
peut-être aussi un mode de désignation
différent j'ai signé une proposition de
loi qui propose de réduire le nombre de
parlementaires ce qui vaut pour les
sénateurs vaut d'ailleurs pour les
députés 348 sénateurs à combien
il y aura plus que 100 sénateurs qui
seront pour le coup des cumulars puisque
ce seront les représentants des
collectivités territoriales ça pourrait
être selon vous le modèle à suivre si on
voulait réformer le scénario c'est un
modèle qui tient la route en tout cas à
partir du moment où on accepte une
République décentralisée il est
parfaitement logique que la deuxième
chambre représente les territoires et
qui représente mieux le territoire que
les élus eux-mêmes donc ils seraient
normal peut-être d'avoir un autre mode
de désignation on pourrait retrouver les
présidents un peu comme le bunstrat et
comme va être le Sénat le Sénat italien
les les élus les grands élus locaux qui
siègent dans la deuxième chambre ne
perçoivent pas davantage et on limite
l'écoute de fonctionnement de la
deuxième chambre c'est en effet on peut
le fonctionnement d'une boule de strat
et récupérer de demander
législatifs dans ce cas-là non une une
vocation législative dès lors que le
législateur ne s'égare pas sur comme il
le fait actuellement depuis des années
sur une quantité de texte qui sont pour
beaucoup
inutiles alors François
Hollande volonté effectivement de
réformer
notamment de diminuer le nombre de
parlementaires on sait que pour ce genre
de réforme constitutionnelle
institutionnelle il faut une majorité
des trois cinquièmes au Congrès est-ce
que vous seriez prêt à suivre le
président de la République vous les
centrist sur ce genre de réforme
institutionnelle
qui non seulement
et émises par le Président de la
République d'ailleurs j'observe qu'il
est pas très enfin ça c'est il y a le
discours et puis en pratique il a pris
aucune disposition
Visante à modifier le Parlement
dès lors que c'est une démarche qui est
suivie aussi par notre groupe le groupe
UDA il y a un certain nombre de mes
collègues qui sont déjà engagés qui ont
consigné cette proposition de loi oui
nous pouvons aller plus loin
pas vraiment faire de révision
constitutionnelle sont notamment l'appui
je crains qu'il ait du mal avec ces
groupes socialistes d'abord les groupes
appartenant à sa majorité supposée vous
évoquez aussi des des réformes en
interne pour pour le Sénat Bercy a
publié vendredi soir le détail de la
réserve
parlementaires des sénateurs c'est à
dire c'est la somme qui est accordée à
chaque élu chaque année pour
subventionner des projets dans son
département ou ailleurs en France alors
quand on voit un petit peu le détail de
cette réserve parlementaire on se rend
compte qu'il y a 15 et le 15 sénateurs
qui trattent plus de 30 % de cette
réserve parlementaire qui atteint quand
même les 54 millions d'euros pour 2013
est-ce qu'il est pas temps d'y mettre un
peu plus de transparence tu en as déjà
un peu plus depuis
je l'ai déjà exprimé je suis favorable à
la suppression de la réserve par le
Monster purement et simplement je sais
bien que cet avis n'est pas partagé par
tout le monde mais moi je pense que ce
serait beaucoup plus simple vous savez
c'est totalement obsolète c'est un
système qui avait été inventé par Michel
Charasse pour s'attirer les bonnes
grâces des parlementaires et faire voter
le budget je pense que ce n'est plus
d'actualité bon pour le moment ça existe
une économie de plus de 50 millions
d'euros pour le sport juste pour le
Sénat
la transparence ce que je fais en tant
que président de groupe c'est de
répartir équitablement strictement
équitablement entre tous les membres du
groupe cette réserve parlementaire ce
qui veut dire que chaque sénateur du
coup
et lorsqu'il reste président de
commission
pas du tout vous confondez peut-être
avec d'autres groupes au groupe U10 ça
ne fonctionne pas comme ça c'est très
simple il y a 5 millions à partir
diviser par 32
et qui siégé
c'est un problème de comptabilité
publique c'est à dire qu'on retrouve par
exemple sur la ligne de Jean arthuy des
crédits qui ont été engagés il y a 4 5 6
ans on peut jouer donc avec les clients
est-ce que certains sénateur qui est
détente de se faire réalire là dimanche
ne peut pas bénéficier d'une partie de
la cagnotte de leur collègue qui n'ont
pas de rendez-vous avec les grands
électeurs alors nous regardons les
quelques sommes qui ne sont pas dépensés
il y en a pas beaucoup et elles sont
affectées au projet qui reste qui sont
portés par les parlementaires qui qui en
expriment la demande mais très
franchement il y a peu de différence je
vous dis c'est 150000 euros pour chaque
parlementaire avec peut-être une pointe
à 180 000 pour quelques-uns qui avaient
d'autres projets on est plus du tout
dans les excès que je
dénonçais mais pour moi la réserve
parlementaire est à supprimer ça doit
être un des chantiers prioritaires du
nouveau restaurant
qui a la main en la matière et le
gouvernement socialiste continue à
utiliser la réserve parlementaire
de la réserve parlementaire il y a aussi
des réserves ministérielles et la
réserve du président de la République
auquel il serait très intéressant de ça
pour des projets qui sont portés par les
communes ou par les communautés de
communes du département que je
représente avec une échelle qui varie
entre 5000 euros par projet pour des
projets de moindre importance jusqu'à
15000 voire exceptionnellement 20.000
euros pour des projets très importants
c'est l'intérêt général et le fait que
les projets soient portés par une
collectivité publique avec des comptes
publics
l'intérêt général sur vous ce serait de
supprimer tout ça un petit mot de la
réforme territoriale on a commencé à en
parler tout à l'heure il y aura une
seconde lecture du projet de loi sur
l'autonomie des sur les régions à
l'automne est-ce que vous espérez que le
Sénat arrivera enfin à trouver un
compromis avec le gouvernement
je doute que nous puissions trouver un
compromis mais enfin c'est pas
impossible parce que le sujet est
vraiment de première importance ce que
pas vers le Sénat en donnant plus
important à la ruralité que je souhaite
oui évidemment on a entendu maintenant
que après avoir parlé des la suppression
des conseils généraux on dit que
maintenant dans 70 départements on
pourra garder le Conseil Général bon
alors c'est la confusion mettez-vous à
la place des élus encore plus de nos
concitoyens personne n'y comprend rien
donc ce que je crois concernant les
régions c'est que il faut que le Sénat
vote une carte des régions nous
représentons les territoires et nous
devons être capables dans la nouvelle
configuration du Sénat d'émettre un avis
clair peut-être ça fera pas plaisir à
tout le monde mais il doit sortir du
Sénat une carte des régions même si le
Sénat est droite
pas envie de s'opposer au gouvernement
et donc à laquelle le gouvernement et du
centre oui enfin de droite
donc nous aurons nous devons avoir la
capacité de proposer une carte au
gouvernement puis ensuite on discute
même si un compromis a été trouvé je le
disais sur la sur la réalité avec le
maintien des départements dans les
départements du ruraux même si pour
l'instant il n'y a pas vraiment de de
stade de ruralité qui est vraiment été
fixée par le gouvernement parce que
quand même vous êtes pas un petit peu
satisfait par cette avancée de Manuel
Valls répété l'autre jour son discours
de politique générale d'entendre
quelqu'un qui est dans l'erreur revenir
à un langage qui est plus qui est plus
conforme à ce que souhaite nos
concitoyens car abandonner des
territoires entiers ce qu'on appelle de
la ruralité mais qui concerne des
dizaines de millions de Français c'était
une grave erreur et il est heureux que
Manuel Valls s'en soit aperçu parce qu'à
partir de lundi si effectivement le
Sénat de la droite avec une nouvelle
majorité de centres droits vous vous
apprêtez à résister à l'exécutif chez
Françoise de en tout cas nous
serons encore plus vigilants que nous
l'étions parce que c'est le projet par
exemple de Jean-Pierre Raffarin il a dit
sur publicité un objectif c'est de
résister à l'exécutif c'est pas résisté
pour le plaisir de résister c'est
devenir un laboratoire pour préparer
l'alternance de 2017
doit revenir dans la proposition et dans
le vote positif il ne peut pas survivre
aux trois années qu'il a vécu année qui
sont tout à fait tragiques pour
l'Institut de centre droit ça va être
difficile peut-être la construction avec
l'exécutif et de travailler maman
et une majorité qui représentée par par
deux groupes sur un projet commun nous
devons discuter et proposer quelque
chose à l'Assemblée nationale et au
gouvernement tragiques vous avez dit oui
parce que c'est peu de dire que le Sénat
pourrait ne pas survivre si une
continuelle comme ça
président et vanessante l'impossibilité
de trouver une majorité un gouvernement
qui est méprisé totalement pendant trois
ans l'institution de la deuxième chambre
qui existe dans tous les régimes
démocratiques c'est c'est pas bon pour
le fonctionnement de la France Merci
monsieur zuketo dernier preuve par trois
spéciales avant les sénatoriales ferry
ce sera jeudi avec Pierre Laurent le
communiste avec qui vous avez quand même
conclu et certaines majorités de
circonstances au cours de ces dernières
années de temps en temps bon on en
parlera avec lui sur certains budgets
merci à tous et à très vite donc